I've tried to surround myself with people that push me,...
...that motivate me, that keep me focused on the right things in this life.
I have that on this stage right here.
I have that in my family, and for that,...
...I'm extremely blessed and extremely thankful for that.
This is a crazy world, and to have that kind of guidance and that kind of motivation...
...definitely has allowed me to do what I do on and off the court.
That's my message, just to not be complacent.
People might have thought I couldn't be back here on this stage,...
...and I tried to push myself and tried to achieve...
...what could not be achieved, and that's something...
...I'm very, very proud of.
So, thank you very much for this award.
Thank you for supporting us every single day,...
...and let's win a championship.